my wife is a very very very cool lady
she's very cool she has to be to put up
with me and I I actually knew that I was
going to marry her on our first date we
ever went out of it I had gone out the
night before and had gotten a little too
drunk and my stomach was really not
feeling very good but I knew I didn't
want to cancel on her so we all to
dinner and it was one of those magical
nights guys and I really do hope
everybody has a night like this where
you're sitting across from the person
that you basically know you're gonna
spend the rest of your night life with
and I've sent across myrrh and we're
laughing and we're joking and things are
going amazing and I feel a sneeze coming
on I sneeze like this ah like I'm a lot
like a mouth freezer the [ __ ] worst
the mouth sneezer is the worst so I
don't want to scare her on our first
date so instead of haha I plug my nose
and when I plug my nose I [ __ ] my pants
swear to God first date future wife
poopy pants everybody right and I'm
sitting there in the expression she must
have seen it change on my face cuz it
was like
because she reached over and she grabbed
my hand and she was like I know it's a
great date I feel it too and I was like
and I hope you don't feel it from across
the table she say excuse me I have to
use the restroom and I was thinking you
have to use the restroom I am the
[ __ ] restroom at this point in time
right so what's my instinct when she
leaves what as mine as a man what's my
instinct run you know why I didn't do
that ma'am I'd [ __ ] in my pants that's
why I didn't do that that's one of the
you know that that's this run here you
know that that terrible that terrible
run from your car to your front door
with your keys in your hand like this
[ __ ] that
by the way let me ask everybody speaking
of which when you're in your car why do
you have to ship more when you see your
house like what is it about your house
sometimes I don't even know I got a [ __ ]
I pull into my driver and I go mad a
[ __ ] up my car
crazy right I'm not the only person to
ever [ __ ] in the front lawn am I am I
the only person
so I decided I just I got a I got a tell
her yes what else I have run through the
rolodex in my head I got nothing I gotta
be honest with her so she comes back she
sits down I said I have to tell you
something and she said you could tell me
anything and I said or we're about to
find out are we
I [ __ ] my pants you know what she said
you know how I knew she was for me she
looked me straight in the eye and she
goes well he knew it I know you [ __ ]
your pants I'm sitting two feet away
from you you don't think I can smell
that you [ __ ] your pants
everybody in this section knows that you
have [ __ ] in your pants and I was like
no way and the guy next to me was like
yeah dude
she said you know I went to the bathroom
so you could leave with some dignity but
you're here when they get back what's
the deal with that
and I said how are we gonna get out of
here she said well we're gonna pretend
like you're [ __ ] and walk you out
the front door that my friends is love
[Applause]